[Music]
[Music]
and to me
our sexuality drives us it's the core of
every single human being it drives us
more than politics religion
um society culture it's the drive in all
of us
[Applause]
sex has been and in many ways still is a
currency
for women and when you flood the market
with goods
you devalue the currency
i think that we just haven't been given
the chance we haven't been given
enough opportunities to be able to be
the women that we want to be
we've got um a rather sexy
debates topic promiscuity and power
so this is a late night broadcast from
london with
four women talking promiscuity and power
what could go wrong
so i'm going to go into the debate
description first just to um have a bit
of foreplay
and then we'll get started so from henry
viii
to warren beatty and fidel castro men
have often gained status by being seen
to have many women in contrast
women have traditionally protected their
virginity before marriage
and monogamy thereafter but a new
generation of young women
proudly proclaim their sexual appetites
and conquests
while promiscuous men are labeled
players
told to sanitize their locker room talk
improve their respect for women
through monogamy is this the welcome
reversal of millennia of male
dominance empowering women and giving
them control over their personal lives
or is it an illustration is it an
illusion
to imagine that the majority of women
want to be sexually asserted and instead
are attracted to men who are
and what is more likely to make women
happy
and relationships successful
with me to discuss this are three
excellent speakers
first we've got emma sale she's a
leading sex entrepreneur
and ceo of killing kittens a sex party
company committed to female empowerment
we've got miriam francois who's a writer
broadcaster and cultural critic
who frequently pends for publications
including the guardian
the huffington post and new statesman
and who's a research associate
at psoas university and last definitely
not least
chanzia mirza is a multi-award-winning
stand-up comedian
actress and writer best known for her
critically acclaimed show
the kardashians made me do it which is
hilarious
to start us off for three minutes first
will be emma sale
should women approach sexual
relationships differently
from men sorry
um my answer is not a simple
yes or no because as far as i'm
concerned it's a very ambiguous question
that implies that all men approach
relationships in
in exactly the same way um and to me our
sexuality
drives us it's the core of every single
human being it drives us more than
politics religion
um society culture it is the drive in
all of us but yet women's sexuality in
the western world is the most
controlled misunderstood suppressed
part of any western women um and
so to me it's not a question of should
we be approaching
relationships the same way as men it to
me the question
is more what is stopping women
approaching relationships
in the same way as men and we as far as
i'm concerned women should have the free
the same freedom and the same choice
to have to go into relationships the
same way as men to
look out there and say this is what i'm
desiring this is what i'm feeling this
is what my
core sexuality is wanting but the
problem is
society and religion and culture and
from the minute we're born
we have this messaging into us
from our mothers from the women around
us and even the most open-minded moms
like my mum
that at the end of the day they didn't
have the opportunities we had
so that messaging into us on having to
compromise put up settle
just lie back and think of england and
be grateful and to think
small is is this kind of and most women
out there
might we go no that's bollocks we don't
think that but
it's it's in there and it's in our
unconscious bias it's there and so
the irony is pre-17th century women were
the ones who were the most lustful sex
and then 18th 19th centuries came along
and religion came along
and culture and society came along and
squashed women
and squashed our desires and
and told us that we shouldn't be doing
it and that shame and that sin
and it's that bit as far as i'm
concerned we should be going out there
and seeing the same opportunities as men
do and
basically backing ourselves and finding
our power and harnessing it
sexually to without fear of judgment
without fear of control without fear of
shame and go into a society where
there's no none of the victim blaming
where the emphasis is all on the woman
it's not on the woman why should we wear
longer skirts why should we not go out
at two in the morning
you know everything's put on the woman
as the blame the man
has no responsibility so to answer that
question
is we should have the same freedom and
the same choice
to go out there and have whatever
relationship
at that point in our life we want
in the same way men do there's no such
thing
as a one way of going into a
relationship
so that's my answer thank you very much
as a great
and powerful start um and now we can
move on to second base with miriam
francois
um thanks so um i think i have to agree
with emma overseeing
in terms of sort of generalizations
about men and women we're very
uh it's very rigor these days to to make
these uh sweeping generalizations about
what men and women want and to sort of
oppose them
uh fundamentally and i think you know
the the studies at least that i've read
and the books i've read seem to suggest
there's actually probably a lot more
overlap
um in what we want then uh we are led to
believe in in a lot of the debates and
this issue
um should women approach sexual
relationships differently from men like
women should approach sexual
relationships
uh based on what they want out of the
interaction which is
itself rarely in my opinion just
sex although of course it can be so
sex for me isn't simply a pleasurable
exchange of bodily fluids
sex has been and in many ways still is a
currency
for women and when you flood the market
with goods
you devalue the currency throughout
history
sex was linked to marriage because the
risks of pregnancy and attendance social
and personal costs
were too high to consider outside of a
support network which is what marriage
guaranteed
i see that as quite separate to sexual
desire which
to be honest continued to manifest
itself in the various forms of illicit
relationships which ended up
uh creating babies that were then left
in
orphanages and continue to be in many
parts of the world
left because that's not considered to be
either desirable socially culturally or
because it's too
not economically viable for women
outside of a marital
set up so sex isn't just sex for women
most of the time um i don't believe that
most women
approach women approach a situation
looking
purely at sex which sounds quite
mechanical to me
uh sex is one component of an engagement
and so ultimately our choices with
regards to sexual activities
should be determined by what you're
ultimately
seeking out of that engagement now
matchmaker's always warn
don't sleep with him on the first date
uh you or you probably won't see him
again
um any regular tinder user will tell you
very similar stories
partly because the climax of the
encounter having passed
at least from his perspective it's on to
new conquests
this isn't because women don't want sex
it's because sex
is a currency a powerful sensual
currency which when harnessed
appropriately ensures we stand
in our power as women we are beautiful
we are sensual we are deeply sexual
we don't need a man's penis to validate
that
so the question is what do you want from
that man
and how are you how are you wielding
your sexual samurai sword in order to
acquire it
wonderful food for thought there
um because of time i'm going to take us
straight to third base
over to you hello um i don't know what
i'm doing on this panel because
i am a female stand-up comedian
so i have never had the chance to be
promiscuous
and i certainly don't have any power i
mean
what it is is what i've seen after doing
gigs is that
men get shagged like no other
and honestly they're not funny and
they're not good looking
but they have cues of women queuing up
to shag them i've seen them
i've been at the comedy store on stage
with these guys
and afterwards there are women queuing
up to have sex with these
men and they can die on stage
and still get sex let me tell you that
has never happened for a woman
i have never i've stormed it i've been
hilarious
nobody's queued up to have sex with me
and it's not because i'm not attractive
or anything like that it's men are
scared of funny women
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas